so who looks after the interests of the
poor certainly not the BJP is it who saw
what is saying is totally gone I
challenge them that gainful whitelist
artistic dipwad you managed to remove a
judge who was asking awkward questions
about your politicians that's the some
of it isn't it
India's government is in the firing line
at home and abroad
accused of badly handling the
coronavirus chipping away at democracy
and lying about a recent battle between
its own troops and Chinese forces in the
far north my guest this week from New
Delhi is Sudan Chu Trivedi
a member of the upper house of
parliament and a national spokesperson
for the ruling BJP why does his party
seem to show so much tolerance to those
who fan the flames of communal hatred
[Music]
Sudan choo-choo vaidhi welcome to
conflict zone let's talk about India's
response to the pandemic first of all
various aspects of your governments
response have been massively criticized
both inside and outside India are much
the 24th your prime minister mr. modi
gave Indians just four hours notice of a
lockdown something that one Indian
writer called the most punitive and
least planned lockdown in the world what
did you expect a hundred million migrant
workers spread out across the country to
do with just four hours notice if you
want to understand what verily I stands
in this situation in this issue of poet
you slightly keep apart China then we
are the biggest nation in the world with
a hundred and thirty five crore
population with 70 percent of the people
living in rural areas with 27 percent is
still illiterate with 30 percent living
below poverty line do you know the
Indian Railways every day 25 million
people travel by Indian Railways so
whosoever is saying that more time
should have been given or locked down
they should consider three four things
number 1 when this pandemic broke out in
the month of January
there was only one laboratory media
which was capable of doing the tests now
there are hundreds of Netherlands so at
the time we were not that much equipped
for testing second thing at the time
there was no production of EB kids
because they were not for mass
production
they were used only in the hospitals in
critical care unit section now we are
acute with the truths second thing there
were very less number of ventilators 13
okay I understand I understand mr.
Trivedi but millions of workers were
left stranded in cities with no food
shelter money or means of transport did
nobody in your government think of that
when the announcement was made it is big
do humility I would like to say this is
a totally wrong fact a proper food has
been provided to all those weary the
IDenticard he went food was provided
those who are not having any IDenticard
second thing direct money has been
transferred 2,000 rupees to every
farmers 500 rupees to every Reuben and
those who are living below poverty line
they were provided gas cylinders three
months free of course this I am talking
about only the government initiative
what I'm just telling you that that the
UN the UN did not buy your comforting
assurances UN experts said just three
weeks ago we report at the disregard
shown by the Indian government towards
internal migrant laborers especially
those who belong to marginalized
minorities and lower caste they said
you'd failed to address their dire
humanitarian situation subjected them to
police brutality and failed to stop
their stigmatization as virus carriers
I'm telling you telling me they don't
know what they're talking about at the
United Nations or wanting first I would
like to complete the forty one thousand
twelve rupees had been provided to 39
crore persons eight poor farmers means
eight hundred million farmers what
provided two thousand rupees each direct
cash transfer in their respective
accounts so there was nothing of this
sort can you imagine a population of
eight hundred millions if they are
living in rural area what could have
been a situation in the government of
not taking a proper action and the due
respect I would like to say all the
international media see there are
certain elements in our system which try
to give wrong information to them there
are such let's talk about some of the
bodies we
in India because some of your leading
medical bodies also trashed the
government's response didn't they the
Indian Public Health Association the
Indian Association of preventive and
social medicine the Indian Association
of epidemiologists they accused you of
incoherent and often rapidly shifting
strategies and policies relying on the
predictions of modelers that they said
were way off the mark
how do you open to that charge nyah
now I answer those who are saying this
we are the biggest democracy of the
world and we do respect I would like to
say from Eastern Europe Japan we are the
only surviving fighting democracy so
Prime Minister has taken consultation
with all the opposition with all the
chief ministers of the state and then
the LOB down to what is started prior to
central government has announced for
Indian states have already announced a
lockdown and the name of the four Indian
states Punjab Maharashtra Telangana who
he saw often by the opposition
government so it was the other political
parties in tune with they were realizing
that it is a requirement to knock down
right now Tamil Nadu is still having the
second phase of lockdown so it was taken
with due consultation with all political
leaders Prime Minister has consulted
with experts prime ministers consulted
with the doctors even Prime Minister has
consulted with the various sports and a
religious personal doctor a very dr.
Trivedi if that was all true why by the
second week in June was the Supreme
Court ordering the government to
transport workers back to their homes
within 15 days it also told the police
to cancel all their charges against
those who weren't able to get home by
themselves it's something of a disgrace
isn't it that the Supreme Court actually
has to order your government to do the
decent humane thing that most other
governments would do by themselves so
who looks after the interests of the
poor certainly not the BJP is it the law
and order is a state subjects it's a
hundred percent a state subject the
central government at least
the health is a state subject center is
only controlling the central units so
all these did it was a primary
responsibility of the state governments
to look after that central government
trying to support them with money and
resources unfortunately because of some
mismanagement some state governments I'm
not accusing all some state governments
when unable to perform that much desired
action that has created a little bit of
panic some state government is done very
well
they have created a call center that any
leavener or migrant laborer can register
them give his or her address and then
the subsequent arrangement of they're
coming back to home whether by bus or by
railways would have been managed and the
sense of government has beer for 85% of
the cost of the railway tickets 15% was
towards the state government so if there
is anything to be said on the part of
the government as far as the migrant
labor is concerned it was on the part of
the state governments because finding
out the policies of the state government
well here's something here's something
that is you here is something that is
your responsibility talk to chief ad
let's let's talk about food by the end
of April the Food Corporation of India
had 77 million tons of cereals in stock
but instead of giving it to states with
very little money your ruling party
tried to sell it to them at market rates
something which shocked economists
ritika Kiera from the Indian Institute
of Management for instance said the
government's unwillingness to relent and
give it free to the states is
mind-boggling
they couldn't understand why you were
trying to profit from this grain instead
of giving this global who know didn't
totally Don government has given free of
cost millions of people those who are
not having IDenticard with them the
government has given free of cost 5 kg
of wheat 5 kg of rice some pulses and
all their food packets made so
it is direct money whether it is
transportation cost whether it is food
it is being provided free of cost by
government and then the state
governments are also profit so we do
respond bill T I'm saying whosoever is
saying is to lead on I challenge them
that can provide their statistics they
put on it well his is a statistic from
the Financial Times which reported that
of the the money most of the money that
was given in extra funding it was less
than twelve billion dollars or about
north point four percent of India's GP
GDP that's one of the lowest levels of
relief provided by any Asian economy you
proud of that on the contrary that
Government of India has provided a
relief package e equal into twenty one
lakh crore appeal which is ten percent
of the GD which is ghent percent of the
GD well that figure isn't filtering
through to international experts
that's not filtering through and and
also dr. Trevanian let's look at the
special fund called P Prime Minister
cares PM cares that has also brought a
fresh deluge of criticism from around
the country the Prime Minister launched
this fund with great fanfare
in March received some 1.2 7 billion
dollars in funds which the government
matched why so few details on how this
money has been spent and why no official
audit from the government auditors the
CAG what have you got to hide here again
I would like to see the fund is
constituted in the month of March and
the audit is done there when the
financially accompanies who's saying in
the two months of the procedure to be
done when even the spending is not
properly completed 50,000 ventilators
5000 crore rupees directly being given
by P and K it's fun and it is a purely
government fund in which the Prime
Minister is the chairman Home Minister
is a member and the defence minister is
a member
nobody from any of the other parties
nobody from the other party why aren't
all the documents related to this fund
made public by the lack of transparency
where is the question of lack of
transparency when the financial year
ends then anybody can ask that what was
the expenditure and where it was done
and if it is not sure anybody can ask
the question let the time company and
then it's too late and then it's too
late why don't you release the
information now people are giving money
workers workers have been asked to give
money government workers have been asked
to give money why shouldn't they see
where this money is going now government
has already humidity feels that 20000
ventilators appeared wait for this 5000
rupees to farmers have been given to
this separate details had been given
which expenditures and already taken
place as in the due course of time
whenever further expenditures will be
provided as you know there's been
considerable controversy over the fact
that all all the people in charge of
this fund are from your party and if
it's public money tell the public what's
going on with it
that's the point that people are making
to you you know perfectly well it's been
well reported in the Indian press you
are mislead it is not run by the members
of other parties or done by the members
of the government it's my point it's men
run by members of the government only
there's nobody from any of the other
parties involved in making the decisions
on this on this body nobody nobody why
not can you tell me any financial body
in the Government of India in which a
member of a political party is there i
challenge no institution is there dr.
Trivedi it's not just your response to
the pandemic that's attracted criticism
agency after agency has highlighted the
falling levels of democracy in your
country I noticed a few moments ago you
were highlighting the fact that your
country is a democracy this year's
report from hede at Freedom House spoke
of the Indian government's alarming
departures from democratic norms under
the Prime Minister's BJP it also awarded
you the largest score decline among the
world's 25 largest democracies in its
2020 freedom index are you proud of that
can you tell me any one fact on
the most criticized aspect of your
decline has been the passage last
December of the citizenship law which
uses religion as a criterion for
deciding which illegal migrants can be
fast-tracked for citizenship to measure
favours members of all South Asia's
religions accept Islam which just
happens to be your second largest faith
that's hardly a coincidence is it I will
give the answer in two parts
number one India is the only settlement
country in the Southeast Asia all other
countries are Islamic Republic and the
persecution of non Islamic people is
very much there so it was incumbent on
the part of us to be in the secular
country and the democratic countries of
this region that we should give shelter
to those who are religiously persecuted
so we have not selected anyone come with
we have selected all in those six
regimes in Buddhist Parsees and our
second UN High Commissioner for Human
Rights doesn't agree with you he calls
the law fundamentally discriminatory in
nature and he should know shouldn't he
he deals with human rights abuses
worldwide humanitarian nature you can
actually discriminatory in nature yes
that Muslims are persecuted in their
country then we can consider their
request we are given five hundred
Muslims the citizenship but if Pakistan
or Bangladesh or Afghanistan come and
openly say that yes we persecute Muslims
also then we can consider Ridhima why
does your party why is it so brazen in
attacking its perceived enemies and why
does it tolerate so much hate speech we
have your Home Minister Amit Shah
referring to migrants as termites to be
eradicated in Uttar Pradesh the BJP
chief minister yogi Adityanath
promised revenge against those who
protested against the citizenship
Amendment Act and said they should be
fed bullets not biriyani why are these
people never reined in by your party or
disciplined by your party and allowed to
say these these things again I would
like to say if you go by the report
to go on such our internet biggest abuse
is being use the words of everything
used against the Prime Minister and they
are saying that they are not having to
in the most dastardly words have been
frequently used openly on the
international media openly in the press
openly on the street there was no
barrier no bar at all on the contrary
you know the most popular English
Channel of the country Republic TV whose
a deterrent has been held by police and
questioned for just asking push into a
political part and other generalist and
facing you know dozens of FII can you
put a single instance in any journalist
who says that he's on TV every country's
day afire
why does Kappa Kappa Mishra for instance
of the BJP in Delhi he led a
demonstration calling on people to shoot
the protesters why was he allowed to do
that no it is wrong he had never used
the word true I challenge kindly check
your fact he has used the world though
demonstrators were occupying the road
illegally or one month he has used the
world I am saying to police that put
within three days you remove this
illegal occupation otherwise we will not
hear to you so can you ask and if
somebody is occupying illegally their
Road in front of your house and if you
say within three days it will not remove
by police then we will decide ourself
what to do where is the shooting of the
Trivedi dr. Trivedi in in the aftermath
of the February riots in which more than
50 people died in Delhi most of the
Muslims in the aftermath there was one
of the most telling episodes when the
Delhi High Court heard petitions about
the riots in the city and asked why the
police had not filed cases against BJP
politicians who had advocated violence
the presiding judge doctor Murali da
warned the Delhi police of serious
consequences
for not investigating statements by BJP
politicians he said I'm really appalled
by the state of affairs of the Delhi
police the court had earlier watch
videos of 4 BJP leaders Kapil Mishra
Anurag Thakur
Abhay Varma and parvesh Verma which the
job described as hate mongering hate
mongering how do you get away on that I
would like to correct I think you were
direct on one instance the shootings and
things were not said by Kapil Mishra the
shooting was in the context of the
magnitude but you go by the video what
he said here is the slogan to the
traitors of the country the people said
shoot them yes I agree that when this
type of slogans were raised
he should have refrained and stopped us
but he had not used the word shoot them
in their self he had robbed the judge
the judge coated hate mongering and you
know what happened the photos to the
judge days later he receives a transfer
order at midnight to a completely
different part of the country and the
federal law minister says it was routine
and agreed by the supreme court a
routine transfer at midnight do you
seriously expect anyone to believe this
you you managed to remove a judge who
was asking awkward questions about your
politicians that's the some of it isn't
it now I want to I want to verify you
and that to me make the point number one
a transform of the judges in India is
not done by government it is done by the
Collegium of the course judges second
thing
how convenient how convenient that it
was just after he had a smoke with
questions let me come he doesn't answer
the transfer order was done 12 days
before and that judge in question has
also given the concern 12 days before it
was done but it was not executed it was
in a Duke when he should have been
relieved much earlier again I am saying
it was done 12 days before that's why I
am saying this is misinformation and
propaganda going on in the short time
that we have left
- travail D I'd like to just talk about
the recent battle between Indian and
Chinese troops in the northern Ladakh
region once again this has raised
questions about different versions
coming from the BJP government where
exactly did the fight take place between
Indian and Chinese forces we know that
some of the Chinese forces died we also
know that 20 Indian soldiers were killed
where exactly did this fight take place
specifically on whose side of the border
Prime Minister and made it very clear
neither Chinese troops were able to
enter even Anand
nor any of our post is under their
control that's not what I asked I asked
where the fight had taken place there
are lying or sectional difference in the
line of actual control so line of
military control is there their troops
are there our - and in between there are
several kilometers of area which is a
no-man's land so there is an
understanding in that area in which the
perception defense is there foods can
come and go but they will not erect any
structure with the permanent or campaign
our troops have gone we find out that
ahead of their la see in the that area
they try to find out a temporary
structure they have destroyed it and
forced them back so the battle took
place where on whose territory in the
no-man's land are you saying it did it
happened on near the Chinese in the
Chinese side in the Chinese military
control line in the Loess then this is
where the battle took place with your
forces yes and we have four young forces
were in Chinese territory or in no-man's
land where were they
why is this so difficult why is it so
difficult to tie down then you marketed
line of military control and in between
there is a several kilometres of India
for which there is an agreement that we
will not fire any arm we will not do any
our dual artillery and we will not erect
any temporary structure forget about the
permanent when our two
perpetually they found that in that no
man's land ahead of their line of
control there was some temporary
structure so that they asked them to
withdraw they didn't then the destroyed
that is structure and there the tussle
came back and they were pushed back so
this all happened in to no-man's land is
that right is that what you're telling
me it didn't happen Chinese territory
and it didn't happen on Indians
territory the clear implication from all
this fudging is that the Chinese did
cross into what you regard as Indian
territory but you won't admit that
because you don't want to appear either
weak for letting it happen or worse
being asleep on the job and not reacting
until it was too late which was it no it
was very clear that the Chinese troops
were there the position of Chinese soup
is exactly there as they were there
before the troops of the imposition of
the Indian troops is exactly there as
they were before and in that area in
which there is an agreement that nobody
should come they tried to come they were
pushed I why not just say clearly the
Chinese violated your border or they
didn't we had two different versions we
have the Prime Minister saying no no one
has intruded into our territory or taken
over any post and we had the foreign
minister who said the Chinese side
sought to erect a structure in go one
Valley on our side of the line of actual
control on our side in other words two
different versions from two leading
figures in your government no there was
no difference at all as far as the
Chinese inclusion in the land is
concerned yes of course in Tucson is
there since 1958 they have captured a
certain area of our territory in 1962 so
58 years they are there in our time but
now the defined position is their
military boundary military position
boundary so now they are there in the
military for example if you say that
they are in a vertically yes they are
there in our eight years as far as the
military control position is concerned
it is not altered it is same as it
that's your Trivedi thank you very much
I'm not sure that you've cleared up the
simple question of where it happened but
thank you very much for your answers
thank you
[Music]
[Music]